hey this is Prestel Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
fun little algebra problem solve for all
real numbers X for which x squared minus
7x plus 11 all raised to the power of x
squared minus 13x plus 42 is equal to
one a similar problem was given to high
school students in Massachusetts with an
average of 30 minutes to solve each
question can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so how
can we solve this problem well imagine
that you're stuck on this problem many
students today we'll check on apps and
websites to find step-by-step solutions
before this problem interestingly many
computer solvers do not give the correct
answer photo math which has over a
hundred million downloads cannot solve
this problem it doesn't provide
step-by-step solutions and it's graph
would suggest that there are four
solutions in fact there are six
similarly math way and symbol lab are
able to find four of the solutions but
they miss two of the solutions a graph
on decimals would suggest that there are
four solutions but as I'll demonstrate
in a minute there are actually six
solutions to its credit Wolfram Alpha is
able to find all six solutions but since
solvers can miss solutions we definitely
need to check and solve on our own so
how can we solve this problem will work
case-by-case and remember our exponent
rules so one way that we can get a
result of one is if we have one to the
power of any number that will be equal
to one so we need to set the base
equation equal to one
this would imply that x squared minus 7x
plus 11 is equal to 1 and we can factor
this to get the quantity X minus 2 times
the quantity X minus 5 is equal to 0
this gives the two solutions of 2 & 5
but this is not the only way we can get
result of 1 another case is if we have
any nonzero number raised to the power
of 0 that will be equal to 1 so we can
set the exponent equal to 0 this implies
x squared minus 13x plus 42 is equal to
0 we can factor this into X minus 6 and
X minus 7 this will give two solutions
of X is equal to 6 and X is equal to 7
now we also want to check that the base
is not equal to 0 because 0 to the power
of 0 is an indeterminate form so we
quickly do that and we see we have no
problem so in fact X is equal to 6 and X
is equal to 7 are also solutions but
there's one more way that we can get a
result of 1 which all of the solvers
except Wolfram Alpha miss and this is
the case where we have negative 1 raised
to the power of an even number that will
be equal to 1 so we need to set the base
equal to negative 1 and we need to check
if the exponent is an even number so we
set the base x squared minus 7x plus 11
equal to negative 1 we then solve this
equation by factoring and we get two
solutions of X is equal to 3 and X is
equal to 4 and I should say there are
two possible solutions because we then
need to check that the exponent is even
so we check that the exponent in each of
these cases will be an even number and
12 and 6 are even numbers so in fact X
is equal to 3 and X is equal to 4 our
actual solutions so these are the six
solutions to this problem X is equal to
2 3 4 5 6 & 7 and I'll leave you with a
little joke what happens if you multiply
all of the solutions
you need to read out the following
sentence did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video these math
videos which can be watch for free on
YouTube inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or mat
topic presh
and mind your decisions calm if you so
choose you can check out my merchandise
which is listed on teespring
you can check on my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support